[Musica]
buonasera nei prossimi minuti
proverò a parlare di due parole molto
semplici aria e respiro a destinare a
1800 metri
è un modo per raccontarci che la
montagna da sempre vissuta come un luogo
salubre che fa bene che previene
malessere le malattie e l'aria oggi è
però anche inquinamento e anche un'area
come dire che ha perso la sua virtù e
quindi oggi il problema
dell'inquinamento è un problema che ci
riguarda tutti che riguarda le
popolazioni che riguarda i ricercatori
che vogliono capire cosa succede nella
nostra salute ma riguarda anche i
decisori quelli che devono preoccuparsi
della salute collettiva e quindi quando
noi pensiamo ai bambini pensiamo alla
montagna
pensiamo a qualcosa che ci possa aiutare
aiutare nella riabilitazione
respiratoria ecco di questo vorrei
parlarvi perché la situazione è questa
che vedete questa è la pianura padana
un'immagine satellitare che ormai è
quotidiana è quello che hanno definito
in giro per il mondo un buco nero di
questo pianeta in cui le polveri sottili
ma non sono gli ossidi di azoto da
inquinamento
le macchine e dei mezzi di trasporto e
l'ozono che ha i più alti livelli
d'europa nella stagione calda in pianura
padana sono causa di malattie e anche
livelli di mortalità davvero importanti
e quindi vi volevo far vedere anche
questo perché uno solo degli elementi
che di cui ci occupiamo cioè le
particelle respirabili queste sono le
famose pm 2,5
voi vedete che la polonia cimitero a
cracovia le grandi fabbriche sono causa
di grave inquinamento ma che tutta la
nostra pianura padana in verità
interessata in un modo molto diverso dal
resto d'europa
qualcuno ha fatto qualcosa noi dobbiamo
fare ancora tutto e questo è quello che
succede quando un bambino viene in un
posto pulito sale in montagna a 1800
metri arriva che ha un litro e poco più
di flusso respiratorio e 24 ore dopo a
più di 2 litri e 200 cioè ha raddoppiato
il suo flusso respiratorio solo perché
ha cambiato ambiente non abbiamo fatto
ancora nulla
questo è quello a cui noi ci dobbiamo
dedicare e cosa succede oggi a un
bambino che respira male
succede che il suo polmone cresceva le
succede che mentre noi respiriamo
normalmente senza pensarci senza
percepire cosa stiamo respirando i
bambini che hanno l'asma o chi soffre di
malattie respiratorie ha una percezione
diversa del suo respiro della sua
sofferenza e
la fatica che si fa ad espirare per
questo io vi inviterei a mettere una
mano sul vostro torace ea respirare
normalmente ispiriamo espiriamo e quindi
per la prima volta forse sentiamo come
si muove il nostro torace quando
respiriamo ma se lo fate con più
intensità a fondo un respiro lungo a
fondo vi accorgete che il movimento è
più percepibile e anche non solo
classico toraco addominale poi
immaginate un bambino che quando respira
fa sempre questo questa fatica anche per
piccoli sforzi
immaginatevi che questa percezione
a noi sfugge noi non ci accorgiamo di
cosa respiriamo noi non sappiamo
esattamente che stiamo respirando
potremmo però prenderne coscienza
possiamo controllare il nostro respiro
sia quando respiriamo normalmente si sa
quando facciamo scorsi abbiamo delle
emozioni perché questo è normale aumenta
la nostra frequenza respiratoria e oltre
a scambiare aria e inquinanti
scambiamo anche ossigeno perché di
quello abbiamo bisogno per vivere e
quindi noi aumentiamo il nord con il
nostro sforzo
il numero di atti respiratori minuto
il nostro problema è esattamente questo
noi vorremmo cambiare il destino di chi
ha malattie respiratorie perché in
questi anni la sma le allergie sono
aumentate come tutti sanno in maniera
esponenziale in questi anni parliamo
degli ultimi decenni
per la verità è questa in rapporto anche
a quella situazione ambientale che voi
avete visto
e questo in qualche modo a un destino
perché di farmaci sono migliorati negli
ultimi anni
ma nessuno di noi è riuscito a cambiare
il destino di chi sviluppa asma
bronchiti croniche e altre malattie
respiratorie per cui il del tempo in
verità questo polmone cresce meno cresce
peggio
abbiamo tutti dei tragitti in cui
forniamo il nostro polmone ma sfugge ai
più che il polmone cresce fino a 18 anni
e che intervenire presto è un problema
fondamentale per cambiare il destino
respiratorio che la metà dei bambini che
soffrono di asma diventeranno degli
adulti con l'asma e degli anziani che
hanno la bronchite cronica che è una
malattia piuttosto impegnativa sia per
le ospedalizzazioni sia per le medicine
e poi anche per l'ossigeno dipendenza
che può dare e quindi quando cambiamo il
nostro destino lo cambiamo quando
riusciremo ad aumentare il volume
respiratorio cioè 18 anni perché prima
riusciamo ad aumentare i flussi
riusciamo a fare usare medicine ma usare
anche un'altra cosa importante che è
importante per tutti noi che fare
movimento avere una vita sana mangiare
più frutta e verdura e quindi tutte
quelle cose che sono lì i sani delle
sane abitudini di vita
noi possiamo intervenire pensare di
utilizzare la montagna utilizzare i 1800
metri dove avviene spontaneamente questo
perché abbiamo dimostrato che in pochi
giorni in 15 giorni in un ambiente
pulito diminuiscono rapidamente tutti i
processi infiammatori a livello
bronchiale e un bambino che a casa non
riusciva a giocare perché mi dicono sei
fermo ogni volta che si muove perché gli
viene la tosse
dopo 24 ore in montagna gioca a pallone
possiamo fare un programma di
riabilitazione respiratoria
ma vedete la montagna è solo come si
dice un piccolo paradiso che abbiamo a
disposizione in verità noi dovremmo
cambiare la pianura
dovremo cambiare le nostre case perché
dobbiamo cambiare le nostre case perché
abbiamo scoperto che quella roba fuori
casa vale 1 ma l'inquinamento in casa
vale nove le case sono diventate delle
camere a gas
respiriamo tutto quello che sta lì
dentro abbiamo messo le gomme alle
finestre e siamo in condizioni di vivere
chiusi a respirare che cosa guardate
sotto i vostri lavandini o nei vostri
ripostigli dalla la cosa per accendere
il camino ai detergenti alle vernici a
gli anti tar ma per arrivare alla fine
al killer della nostra vita che è il
fumo di sigaretta
le case sono diventate veramente
tossiche
quindi bisogna aprire le finestre
bisogna tirar via qualche gomma la
finestra che ci aveva fatto risparmiare
come si dice un po di riscaldamento però
il nostro problema è che possiamo
portare i bambini montagne possiamo
riabilitarli ma se quando tornano a casa
tornano allo stesso ambiente di prima
non abbiamo ottenuto un grande risultato
dobbiamo pensare a come cambiare il
destino respiratori come aumentare il
nostro volume respiratorio e perché
dobbiamo cambiare dobbiamo cambiare
perché quando lui smettiamo di crescere
e mediamente intorno ai 18 anni
noi abbiamo un volume polmonare che più
o meno resta invariato fino a 25 anni ma
anche qui non si pensa spesso che a 25
anni si incomincia ad invecchiare e dai
25 anni in poi perdiamo 30 c c l'anno di
volume respiratorio cioè perdiamo
progressivamente ogni dieci anni
mediamente 300 cc chi fuma invecchia due
anni ogni anno che passa quindi perde il
doppio e avvelena anche agli altri con
cui vive per altro ma questa faccenda
vuol dire che ci giochiamo la vecchiaia
noi dobbiamo pensare ai bambini perché
quel volume che raggiungeremo alla fine
della crescita è quello che useremo per
invecchiare e la nostra qualità di vita
dipende da quello che oggi otteniamo va
di moda dire che i primi 1000 giorni di
vita decidono la nostra vita è
profondamente vero da quando abbiamo
incominciato a scoprire l'epigenetica ma
per il respiro è particolarmente vero
quindi noi dobbiamo fare alcune cose
usare bene i farmaci usare anche
l'altitudine per questo scopo di
riabilitazione un posto dove i bambini
possano fare attività fisica abbinata al
ai farmaci in e con attività strutturate
di tipo riabilitativo voi immaginate
questa roba l'abbiamo imparata dai
quelli che vanno in montagna dai medici
di montagna a chi è stato su alla
piramide sotto k2 a studiare il polmone
ed agli atleti ed alla medicina sportiva
dobbiamo allenarci tutti dobbiamo
allenarci perché camminare mezz'ora al
giorno è la condizione per vivere meglio
anche a 70 anni ma ripeto noi abbiamo in
mano il destino e il futuro di chi
dovrebbe prepararsi avere una vita
normale a respiratoria e quindi noi
possiamo pensare che l'aria prima di
tutto deve essere pulita dentro e fuori
casa averne coscienza e la cosa più
importante che possiamo avere per fare
le cose giuste
poi possiamo usare anche la montagna e
questo si chiama andare incontro alla
salute per tutti noi
grazie
[Applauso]